Speaker 1: Hey, this is this is kind of funny.
We are now on rumble. The right wing network
we we they rumble claims to be the free speech
platform. Everything is allowed. It's all allowed.
Respectfully, it's all everything. Everything's
just all good. So we put some of our content
up on Rumble. We have 247 subscribers as of right
now. We're just putting our liberal content on
there and we're going to see what happens.
We're going to figure out, are they really
the free speech platform or do we get ourselves
banned? Do we get ourselves shadow banned? Because
remember all of the claims that the right
wrongly makes about platforms like YouTube,
Facebook, where the right dominates Twitter, etc.
all the claims that they falsely make? We will now
test on Rumble. Do they deprioritized
us? Do they ban us? Whatever? Now,
maybe they don't. I am really interested to
see what happens. You can find our Rumble
page at David Pakman dot com slash rumble. It'll
redirect you and you know you can subscribe to
our channel or whatever if you do. We had a really
good time during our stream with this. Make sure
you're leaving comments about just how great it is
that we finally have liberal content on here and
whatever. That being said, a lot of people
are not thrilled that we are on rumble.
One guy who goes by the handle American guy almost
immediately when we posted our first clip showed
up and said, And here come the Liberals with
their socialist agenda to corrupt this beautiful
website. We need to protect free speech by banning
these Satanists and Satanists misspelled as well.
That doesn't sound like the model of free
speech that the platform is founded on. Doesn't.
Another user said, I think this is
the only left wing channel on Rumble.
Well, Jimmy Dore is on there. I thought he was
left wing, maybe not American guy. Then tracking
us all over, we posted the Marjorie Taylor Greene
struggling to breathe while talking about mask
video. An American guy says she's struggling
to breathe because the demon rats keep
forcing her and her constituents to wear a mask.
But she's there every day at the White House,
fighting the good fight. Actually, she doesn't go
to the White House and making sure laws follow the
Constitution. And then lastly, a user named Parren
Cho says, You hypocrite criticize rumble in Rumble
while profiting from it. You must be another
Lib Obama fan. So needless to say, we are not
exactly being welcomed with open arms on
Rumble, but it is a very interesting experiment
and I look forward to seeing what
happens if we get banned. I will
absolutely tell you and you can find our platform
there. David Pakman dot com slash rumble. OK,
I want to make the announcement. We want this
to be a big community event, so I'm starting to
announce it now. We are now three weeks minus
three days. I guess that would be like 18 days
from Joe Biden's much anticipated State of
the Union address. Now you might remember
last year the Republicans and some on the right
wing media were saying Biden can't even stand
for half an hour. He's not even going to be able
to put a coherent sentence together. He's going
to be sundowning at night. All these if it was a
completely normal, uneventful state of the Union.
This year, it is particularly anticipated. Yes,
the right wingers are still doing the dementia
stuff, but it's particularly anticipated because
number one Joe Biden's approval rating at this
point in his presidency is equal to the lowest
we've seen in the polling era. And I mean, you go
back to LBJ, John Kennedy Bush one, Bush two, the
prior prior to Biden, the lowest approval at this
point in time was Trump, and Biden's approval is
down as low as Trump was. So the real question is,
is anything going to be done at the State of the
Union to try to immediately bolster that approval
rating? And one of the things that I think is
under consideration this is my speculation. But
insiders in DC are saying there is pressure on
this, some kind of renewed mission accomplished
on COVID, which some people are very much in favor
of and other people are very much against if it
doesn't happen before the State of the Union. I
expect that something will happen there, pushing
a return to normality. So we will be live on
March 1st, starting an hour before the speech on
YouTube, Twitch and Facebook. I hope you'll join
us. And in the meantime, let me know on Twitter
at De Pacman what you expect to see at the next
state of the Union. Welcome back to the show, the
David Pakman show is viewer and listener supported
media, you can sign up at Join Packman dot com
to get instant access to the Daily Bonus Show, as
well as commercial free audio and video streams of
the show. You can get the show six hours before
the general public every day, which is just on
another level. Sign up at Join Packman dot com
coupon code wwr 22 saves you a bunch of money.